let's answer the question what
is the first sign of a zinc
deficiency now clinically when you're deficient in
zinc all sorts of things happen a lack of growth
anorexia tissue necrosis you can actually
get tissue dying from a lack of zinc
all sorts of skin issues all sorts of digestive
issues infection viruses bacteria hair loss ulcers
and the list goes on and on you don't have a major
deficiency but you're just starting to become
deficient in zinc well to answer that we need
to kind of look at some other data number one
when you're low in zinc you will have a lowered
amount of very specific antioxidants glutathione
alpha tocopherol and catalase which has to do
with the detoxification of hydrogen peroxide
so in other words very powerful
antioxidants in our bodies are dependent on
zinc and without zinc you will not be able
to produce these in sufficient amounts
now there's some additional information
i want to share with you cardiac tissue
or heart tissue is the highest producer of
something called ross so just think about ross as
something that creates a lot of oxidation and the
heart cells as a tissue if we compare it to other
tissues in the body has one the lowest antioxidant
capacity now what does that mean so in other words
it becomes very susceptible to becoming damaged
this is probably why the number one cause of death
is heart disease the heart is not able to repair
effectively and the first symptom is you're going
to get shortness of breath upon exertion so let's
say you start to exercise or you run up the stairs
and you're out of breath easily that would
be the first symptom of a zinc deficiency
so i remember as a kid living on sugar outside
playing and noticing i was having a difficult time
running up a hill i was like out of breath very
easily i had no clue on what that was but it was
probably a zinc deficiency due to all the sugar
that was consuming and so if you have that symptom
watch a lot more of my videos on zinc i put
the links down below check it out hey before
you go real quick i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof your immune system it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why here's you
here is your environment everyone is focused on
this over here avoiding your environment but
what about here what about strengthening your
immune system that's what's missing this course
will show you how to bulletproof yourself and so
you can tolerate and resist your environment
much better by strengthening your own immune
system i put a link down in the description right
down below check it out and get signed up today